ellen my sister right here
now we're supposed to go three to four
we have time okay
all right
go ahead sister so i'm asking this
question for a friend um you had
mentioned
of how you memorize
bible text but can you go into more
detail on how or can you even like give
us an example on how you
or memorize
scripture
spirit of prophecy okay uh i was let's
say when i was memorizing revelation 16.
what is found in revelation 16
let's have last place
if you go to that chapter because when
you memorize you must know where each
individual verse is when you need it you
can't be preaching i need a verse from
revelation 16. let me recite the whole
first the whole chapter till i get to
the verse you can't do that you have to
know which each verse is
i realize
plague number four is in verse eight
tell me if i'm right
plague number five is in verse 10.
plague number six where do you think it
is
verse 12 yes
and plague number seven where do you
think it is 17 no 17
7 17. and so those became markers for me
so i could find a plague now all i had
to do now was focus on the first three
are you with me
but four was in verse eight so you look
at the structure of the passage
for instance let's say when i was
working on daniel 8
in the third year of the reign of king
bel-shala
velshas a vision appeared unto me
even unto me daniel
after that which appeared unto me at the
first of the three and two knees
so you look at that okay there are three
unto me
when you met when i was memorized
genesis 5 and adam lived 130 years and
begat her son in his own likeness after
his image
and called his name seth and all the
days that adam lived for 930 years and
he died now there is a there's a pattern
to all of the patriarchs in genesis 5.
once you get that pattern it becomes
easy to plug in the numbers you see and
all the days of methuselah were 96 or 9
years and he died all the days of limit
was 700 70 years and he died you you see
the formula and you then plug in the
numbers and that comes along with of
course constant counts of repetition
with ellen white it's not quite the same
way
you have to get
as in the bible as well what is the
individual thought there's a beautiful
passage in the
education page 127 paragraph one
with the word of god in his hand
every human being wherever his lot in
life may be cast
may have such companionship as he shall
choose
in its pages he may hold converse with
the noblest and best of the human race
and may listen to the voice of the
eternal as he speaks with men
as he studies and meditates upon the
themes into which the angels desire to
look he may have their companionship he
may follow the steps of the heavenly
teacher and listen to his voice as when
he taught on mountain and plane and sea
he may dwell in this world in the
atmosphere of heaven imparting to
earth's soldering and tempted ones
thoughts of hope and longings for
holiness himself coming closer and still
closer into fellowship with the unseen
like him of old who walked with god
drawing nearer and nearer the threshold
of the eternal world until the portal
shall open and he shall enter in he
shall find himself no stranger the
voices that will greet him are the
voices of the holy ones voices who
unseen were on earth his companions
voices that here he learned to
distinguish and to love
he who through the word of god has lived
in fellowship with heaven will find
himself at home in heaven's
companionship what was she saying i had
to understand the
spirit of the passage of every sentence
she's telling us
you can hang out with bible characters
literally hang out with them by studying
the word of god and their life daniel
joseph little captain whomever you can
hang out literally with bible characters
and by so doing the effect of their
character will change you
so that if you suddenly ended up in
heaven you'd feel at home because you've
been custom hanging out with moses and
david and joseph elijah
this is what she's saying and so once i
got that central message
one of the most beautiful passages i've
ever read in all of eloy's writing
then i looked at every sentence
and you'll forget each sentence
and that's how i do it l white each
sentence
but again it's over
and over
her writings
you cannot escape
constant repetition
everyone wants an easy way there is no
easy way you can't sleep with desired
ages under your pillow and wake up in
the morning and know it it doesn't work
like that you have to but the more you
do it the easier it becomes
we're not willing to try
you know you try for a week you memorize
whatever genesis 1 1 and after two days
you forget it and you give up in
discouragement no you say look i will
get this i'll die
or die trying
you try and then your mind becomes
stronger and stronger
education page 123 paragraph one for the
mind and the soul as well as for the
body it is god's law that strength is
acquired by effort
it is exercise that strengthens
both in the gym
and here
you don't build muscles going to the gym
and doing one rep
you don't build muscles by lifting
pillows are you following me you have to
lift weights
you sweat you grunt you groan you
collapse on the floor
but the muscles start to grow
spiritually you've got to do the same
thing are you with me
don't give up
remember this is for your spiritual
growth
this is for your spiritual strength your
defense against satan is thus
saith the lord at any age
and so my good sister i have no fancy
method my method is brutal
bloody consistent repetition
you know
there's some passages when i was working
on them the names they say where these
people get these names from
jesus
you know genesis 40 came to pass in the
days of amrithal king of china ariel
king of elissa kedo
king of elam and title king of nations
that these midwives with bearer king of
sodom would burst your king of gomorrah
shinab king of admiral shemiba king of
zaborium and the king of bala which is
zoa all these were joined together in
the veil of sin which is the salt sea
twelve years they served kendall aroma
and in the thirteenth year they rebelled
and in the fourteenth year came kettle
roma and the kings that were with him
and smote the rephaims in ashraf name
and the zuzims in ham and the eminence
in chavekyria theme now you've got to go
over that all the time all the time all
the time take medication to get it
because it it drives you nuts
but you say god i'll die i have to get
this
i have to get it and to my amazement
it comes naturally
then again abraham took a wife
her name was katura and she bare him
zimran and jokshan and maida and midian
and ishbak and sure abraham had six more
boys beside isaac and ishmael
genesis 25 six more boys i had to go for
those names go for this dave you know
esau had 12 sons
it was he saw yeah yes esau
and i had to
all the time all the time all the time
all the time all the time these strange
funny names you get into nehemiah oh you
talk about strange names
[Music]
but practice truly
makes perfect i was in south africa many
years ago
a member of the church was formerly a
professional golfer and he told me
every day
he would drive the ball 600 times
to drive it to perfect the action 600
times
i read where kobe bryant and michael
jordan they would shoot a thousand jump
shots
you might miss 800 but they kept
shooting
you have to apply this to god's word
in mark chapter 8 jesus told the
disciples i must go to jerusalem suffer
die rise again. in mark 9 he said i must
go to jerusalem suffer that i rise
again. in mark 10 he tells him the same
thing they never got it immediately
you have to tell them tell them tell
them
repetition
also understanding what the verse is
saying
and a willingness to live by what you
learn
but i'm telling you again if you
practice if you try you will become
better at it you'll be shocked how
quickly there's a young there's a young
lady in zambia
she got my number somehow i don't know
how
text me
hell this kid i
so happy to have your number how can i
memorize i should just just try you in
college just try
she started memorizing chapters
sending me the recordings
and just like just i'm just delighted to
listen to those recording john 17 john
this you know she's
chapters
it's
a family
i hope they're not listening to this
i'll be crucified with a smile on their
faces
i
the mother of that family started
memorizing
working in proverbs got through the
first 10 chapter now problems is a
challenge
because each verse does not necessarily
follow or connect to the next she was up
to chapter 10
in proverbs
this little boy in
botswana memorized all of revelation
there's another little boy in there the
family sent me an audio of him
he was in a bathroom taking a shower
he's about five
but all he ever hears is hymns and the
bible because they live in the country
and the sound of birds and streams
that's all he is
so that's all he can say
and he was in the shower he was taking a
shower when he was preaching and romans
12 1 says i beseech you there and he's
preaching he's preaching washing
and the mother recorded him he didn't
know
and she sent it to me and i just smiled
and he had memorized romans
i said he memorized romans
amen he was five or six
his other brother memorize daniel
children are born with a mind that
absorbs like a sponge
we just have to make sure they absorb
the right because they will learn fast
we have to give them the right exposure
but we still have that mind our minds
were made to learn forever
try apply your mind and let your mind be
revived
try with god's word the writings of
ellen white
pastor skeet i think that that's a
fitting way to
cap off this section okay
and uh
you can you can talk to him individually
i'm sure
so
but i i think that we've all been
inspired amen to hide the word of god in
our hearts
for those of you that are in the college
you know we have these these verse packs
this is this is a good way to do it fast
dan this was around when you were there
for a little bit right and
so so i want to encourage you to
whatever it's three by five cards or
something like this
to to make this a part of our lives if
you've noticed a theme in his life this
is something that that is a part of the
fabric of his being something that he
does by god's grace throughout the day
it is his meditations truly day
and night
and let that be our experience amen
pastor skeet is not an anomaly it's not
an experience that no one else can have
this is available accessible to all by
god's grace and let us live by every
word that proceeds out of the mouth of
god praise his name pastor if you could
close us with prayer all right are there
any prayer requests
none
oh did you have a question
no okay all right
it was a prayer request
oh okay all right okay okay
my oldest son
yes um his grandmother
and his sister passed away oh
he has to go to antigua tomorrow antigua
yeah okay he has to go home there to
funeralize them
that's the prayer request okay what's
his name yo
my name is glenn no no
you said your only son my oldest you
your oldest son yes sir he's going to
funeralize his mother
and his youngest okay what's his name
his name is glenn his name is glenn his
mother name is
liza and his sister name is tia okay his
name i want his name he's glenn what's
glen's last name
lewis yes
okay all right we'll pray for brother
glenn you know one day there'll be no
more death my brother
literally there'll be no more death
the last enemy that shall be destroyed
is death
let me say it again you look as if you
didn't hear what i said
there's coming a day
when there will be you see we can get so
accustomed to something it's hard to
entertain the thought it will no longer
exist there is coming a day
when there will be no more death
i've heard people say what will i do in
heaven it'll be boring no it won't
you deal with a god who can find things
the universe is
give me a minute
what's the name of our galaxy come on
quickly the milky way
to travel from one end of the milky way
to the other at the speed of light
186 000 miles per hour per second sorry
it would take 200 000 years
did you know what i said
to cross the milky way which is one of
billions of galaxies
it would require 200
000 years traveling at the speed of
light 186 000 miles per second now and a
bit now
there are worlds all over the universe
the bible says we will reign with christ
we have work to do
there is coming a time
there will be no more death
no sin
no sickness
but if the church can't believe that
but you see we are so surrounded by
death
whether animals plants people
everywhere you go there's a nice nicely
manicured graveyard
in every city
death
death ukraine wherever death death
it's hard to draw your mind and place
your mind on life without end but that
day is coming
and we have to so live our lives that
when christ comes and in
ushers in that new life
you and i
will be a part of it
i don't want to miss that just for
cigarette
or drugs
or a movie
or some worldly entertainment i don't
want to miss eternal life
for that
any other prayer request
let's borrow heads
our father in heaven we thank you so
much that your invitation to us is
let us therefore come boldly to the
throne of grace and we come in the name
of jesus dear god
if we offended you in any way forgive us
father you love to forgive micah 7 18
tells us he delighteth in mercy and
there's no greater mercy than calvary
dear god
lead us by your spirit into your word
let us find joy in studying your word in
meditating on your word as david said oh
how love i thy law it is my meditation
all the day
in his lord doth he meditate day and
night the righteous man
remember brother glenn going to
funeralize relatives
let the spirit of comfort go within
their father let the angels defend him
and bless all of the family members give
them strength to deal with this great
loss
father bless every student
in the academy in the college
bless the administrators their god
give them wisdom
that this institution may be a light in
this part of the world
give special wisdom to brother shin
father because leadership at any level
is not easy
give him the wisdom of solomon that he
may guide your people a right forward
and upward
provide the needs of the students
sustain the families that sacrifice to
send them to this place
bless us for the remainder of this holy
day i pray and even when the holy day
ends let us be reminded that our
holiness does not end
in jesus name we pray amen
in my state of michigan we still wear
these
so if you think i look like an alien i'm
not an alien
my wife has commanded me
to wear this or don't come back so i
have to wear this
so i thought i'd explain that so you
don't think i'm a strange but i'm
strange but not because of this
i have to wear this god bless you god
bless you i really mean that we see you
at
seven seven o'clock seven o'clock thank
you everyone memorize a verse between
then and now
and tell me what it is